[Musique]
kildonan st paul c'est tout le manitoba
en une seule circonscription un vaste
territoire est essentiellement rural
alors que la population est concentrée
au sud à winnipeg
[Musique]
on y trouve de nouveau développement
domiciliaire cossu ainsi que des
secteurs de logements abordables
kildonan st pal a basculé du bleu au
rouge il ya quatre ans et elle pourrait
changer de couleur à nouveau dans la
bonne humeur morose de tout avec ses
clientes
rien n'est tabou dans son salon de
coiffure aménagé chez elle même pas la
politique et ce qu'elle entend ne lui
laisse aucun doute une des séries à un
cancer bref ces conservateurs dans le
coin dit elle l'agriculture est le coût
de la vie sont les grandes
préoccupations
c'est ce qui joue en faveur de la jeune
candidate conservatrice de 29 ans qui a
fait ses études à mcgill
raquel donne chaud la taxe fédérale sur
le carbone imposée au manitoba fait mal
ici personne n'échappe à cette taxe à la
pompe puisque tout le monde dans la
circonscription à une auto
explique-t-elle les prix du chauffage et
des denrées à l'épicerie ont augmenté en
conséquence les jeunes familles et les
aînés qui ont plus de revenus en soufre
ajoute l initiative à la député libéral
sortant américaines méritent choc a été
ministre de l'emploi du développement de
la main-d'oeuvre et du travail en début
de mandat avant de perdre son poste lors
d'un remaniement elle admet que c'est
une course serrée
astrada dois te faire la passe et que
les électeurs des prairies se sentent
abandonnés par les libéraux de justin
trudeau son chef d'ailleurs si
impopulaire ici qu'il nuit à la campagne
électorale locale sommes très honorés de
retour au salon de marleau elle avoue
être une libérale déçu
so excited bat cet immigrant d'origine
palestinienne votre a malgré tout pour
le parti même si le chef la tire -
soirée d'initiation à la crosse sport
national d'été du canada avec le travail
l'école les activités communautaires
pas facile pour tous les parents de s'y
retrouver en politique
d'autant plus que les manitobains ont
voté au provincial le 10 septembre et
qu'ils retourneront aux urnes pour les
élections fédérales
à peine six semaines plus tard
fanatiques comme de nombreux bénévoles
ont travaillé aussi pour la campagne
provinciale
ils sont exténués les dons sont moins
généreux
le sprint final commence dans kildonan
st paul alors que les candidats doivent
combattre la fatigue de leur équipe mais
surtout la lassitude des électeurs ici
philippe leblanc radio-canada winnipeg